che cos'è la realtà me lo chiedo perché
abbiamo parlato e stiamo parlando
tantissimo di cambiamento di
trasformazione ma forse dobbiamo anche
in cominciare a riflettere sul fatto che
sta cambiando la nostra percezione la
nostra relazione con la realtà
abbiamo parlato di cambiamento di
trasformazione e forse si sta cambiando
la nostra percezione della realtà la
sfida che abbiamo di fronte non è
soltanto la digital transformation non è
soltanto la social transformation non è
soltanto la tec transformation che sono
tutte le trasformazioni e cambiamenti
importanti ma è la human trasformation
perché è vero che l'uomo resta ma non
può restare così nel millennio in cui
siamo entrati noi
parlando di cambiamento stiamo
dimenticando il fatto che cambiare è
difficile sia culturalmente che
organizzativamente e ci sono molti
studiosi di scienze della narrazione di
scienze della comunicazione oggi che si
stanno chiedendo come cambiare per
gestire tutte le grandi sfide che
abbiamo di fronte
io ho provato a identificare tre mostri
che noi ci portiamo dietro come tre
grandi verità del secolo scorso che sono
all'interno delle nostre culture e che
sono anche all'interno dei nostri
comportamenti di vita
questi tre mostri sono fondamentalmente
quelli che vedete scritti qui la
conoscenza e oggettiva che poi porta il
comportamento abbastanza semplificato di
ognuno di noi quando accende la tv
quando guarda i giornali quando si
collega on line sul web o sui propri
profili social di pensare di percepire
che tutto quello che si conosce se
automaticamente vero essendo oggettivo
seconda grande verità i fatti contano
qui
nemmeno nulla da dire o da commentare
terza grande verità del secolo scorso
che noi stiamo ancora vivendo oggi e che
determina gran parte delle nostre scelte
di vita e il consenso e sociale cioè noi
possiamo diventare quello che abbiamo
deciso di diventare a livello di
carriere personali o professionali
se il gruppo di riferimento la comunità
di riferimento ce lo permette ci dà un
consenso un dissenso in questo giusto
ecco in quanti facciamo un piccolo test
e in quanti si riconoscono in almeno una
di queste grandi verità di comportamento
alzate la mano per favore venne quasi
l'unanimità direi molto bene
ecco queste oggi sono un po verità
problematiche per noi perché stiamo
entrando siamo ormai entrati in un mondo
molto molto diverso non solo a livello
tecnologico non solo a livello sociale
ma anche a livello culturale
queste tre verità ci portano a percepire
la realtà come qualcosa di costante
certo ed eterno e quindi produce una
forte resistenza al cambiamento e ci
porta ad eliminare tutta quella
dimensione fantastica immaginaria
creativa passionale narrativa che
naturalmente abbiamo un po relegato o
come come dire perdita di tempo o
tutt'al più come intrattenimento
letterario filmico televisivo no leggete
un libro se sei stanco e divertiti e
distrae t in realtà le due cose si
stanno fondendo sempre di più e voglio
farvi riflettere su alcune questioni che
secondo me sono estremamente importanti
vale a dire il fatto che noi oggi
viviamo in comunità sempre più
immaginaria dove il fantastico la
narrazione il racconto in senso lato
diventano format di vita e di
riferimento diventano dei veri medium di
collegamento che io ho portato alcuni
tra i profili social ovviamente più
famosi e interessante però se ci
riflettete notare che la maggior parte
di questi profili sono immaginati e
immaginari che cosa raccontate voi i
vostri profili raccontate solo alla
verità dei fatti ho raccontate una serie
di situazioni immaginarie che fanno
parte della vostra vita
pensate mangiate un buon piatto forse
stasera infatti una foto ci mettete un
filtro un bel l'astag e questa cosa ma
subito online
quella foto col fisco col filtro e con
la star non è più la verità non è più il
dato di fatto di partenza
questa è una cosa molto importante
perché all'interno di queste comunità
che abitiamo e che viviamo questo è
fantastico e nessuno io non sto né
criticandone lodando questo tipo di
comunità
ma le comunità che noi abitiamo sono
sempre più fantastiche questa è un
esempio clamoroso di cui siamo venuti a
conoscenza in italia negli ultimi mesi
la comunità delle mamme pancin e sapete
cosa sono
sapete chi sono meravigliose perché sono
scese in campo difendendo la maternità
rispetto per esempio a una pubblicità
dove c'è una mamma che viene uccisa da
un meteorite
ecco è interessante vedere come il
racconto diventa una nuova forma di
espressione di se e come la narrazione
oggi alla dimensione fantastica quindi
ci aiutino a rappresentarci in modo
diverso anche in modo controfattuale
come vedremo fra poco
questa è una foto reale che ho tratto da
la pagina da una delle pagine facebook
di queste comunità
a tantissime a tantissimi iscritti vi
consiglio di darci un'occhiata perché ci
sono parecchie cose da imparare
un'altra cosa che sta succedendo e che
trovo straordinaria è che all'interno
delle nostre comunità narrative sempre
più fantastiche sempre più lontane dai
fatti dai fatti concreti intendo quelli
su cui noi siamo stati educati
formativamente la narrazione non è più
soltanto intrattenimento una docu
fiction con un film un libro ma sta
diventando una forma di sperimentazione
di contro realtà questo è un caso che è
straordinario è una docufiction prodotta
da animal planet che è un canale biel
gruppo discovery è andata in onda tra il
2011 e il 2012 in due puntate di due ore
ciascuna
questa docu fiction dimostra l'esistenza
delle sirene
la prima puntata si intitola sirene
mistero svelato una seconda puntata si
intitola sirene il corpo ritrovato
questa è la docu fiction più seguita
nella storia di vita del canale animal
planet ha 17 anni ed è in assoluto la
fiction più seguita tanto è vero che ci
hanno costruito addirittura ultimamente
tutta una serie di pagine di contenuti
nei loro social network
ma al di là di questo quello che è
interessante è stato questo dopo che
questa fiction è andata in onda negli
stati uniti prima e poi l'anno dopo
arrivato in europa e in italia
moltissime persone americane hanno
chiamato la noah si sono messe in
contatto con la noah che è l'agenzia
governativa americana per il controllo
dell'atmosfera degli oceani per chiedere
se le sirene esistono
la nuova non ha detto di no non ha detto
no
smentiamo non esistono questo è la
pagina di dichiarazione ufficiale della
noah la quale ha detto che non ci sono
abbastanza evidente scientifiche per
negare l'esistenza delle sirene capite
quindi stiamo vivendo in un momento
veramente molto strano molto particolare
in cui la fiction si mescola sempre di
più con la realtà e quindi la dimensione
fantastica che prima era relegata alla
letteratura e all'intrattenimento oggi
diventa un format importantissimo di
produzione del valore sociale politico
ed economico
questo cosa credete che sia perché
dobbiamo fare una riflessione noi siamo
talmente immersi nella fiction che non
ci rendiamo neanche più conto che è lo
stesso denaro oggi è la finzione più
grande attenzione per finzione non dico
menzogna non significa menzogna o
qualcosa di finto significa qualcosa che
viene costruito narrativamente la cosa
interessante dei b coin e che
addirittura anche il cosiddetto
fondatore è un personaggio misterioso
sapete che non si sa esattamente chi
abbia creato i bitcoin pare che sia un
certo satoshi nakamoto però non c'è
sicurezza
quindi stiamo non solo vivendo una
fiction ma addirittura in una fiction
specifica una sorta di spy story e se
notate tutte le grandi narrazioni in cui
noi oggi siamo immersi sono sempre più
basate sulla suspense e su come dire
questa dimensione di mistero e di
misteriosità nella nostra era narrativa
lo dicevamo poco fa e nella nostra era
sempre più fantastica stanno saltando i
paradigmi di fattualità i fatti contano
sempre di meno
oggi abbiamo sentito che la terra è
rotonda da evidenti colleghi e
scienziati e il problema è che ci sono
sempre più persone nel mondo non solo
che credono alle sirene agli alieni
eccetera eccetera ma anche dal fatto che
la terra sia piatta e norton da e stanno
optando scienziati ricercatori studiosi
per dimostrare al mondo che la terra è
piatta e la cosa a qualcuno la prende
sul serio perché elon musk dialogare
costantemente con la flat sos haiti
la società americana della terra piatta
questo è un tweet reale di un paio di
settimane fa dove loro hanno uno scambio
tra ludico e simpatico
la cosa interessante in questa era
fantastica e controfattuale sono un po
di ricerche che stanno emergendo perché
è un tema come voi potete capire molto
nuovo molto aperto e su cui bisogna
discutere dibattere di battere e
ricercare tantissimo allora c'è
un'interessante ricerca di stanford che
ha fatto tra il 2015 2016 su un panel di
oltre 7000 giovani studenti numero
esatto 7.804 persone tra i 13 e 19 anni
e sono emerse cose incredibili
molti inaspettate ma che confermano
quello di cui stiamo discutendo cioè
l'ottanta per cento delle persone
mediamente in età di 13 anni non
riusciva a distinguere un contenuto
normale da una pubblicità il 70 per
cento complessivo dell'intero campione
valutava valutato l'affidabilità dei
contenuti dal punto di vista dei numeri
sostanzialmente è la like economy più
laica i più conta quello che stai
dicendo
il 40 c 40 per cento dei ragazzi
coinvolti trasversalmente giudicava
potenzialmente positiva e attendibile
dei giudizi o dei commenti in base alla
narrazione che l'articolo riportava e
quindi non ha l'autorità della fonte
rispetto al fatto che quello che veniva
raccontato era emozionante significativo
non che fossi io foste voi a farlo ci
potremmo dire vabbè sono giovani vabbè
devono imparare
vabbè quali lasciano americani con gli
altri sono cinesi no sono creduloni non
sono credulone il problema è che è molto
più complesso il tema di cui stiamo
trattando c'è il fatto che noi mixiamo
insieme si chiama blending questo
meccanismo psicologico i fatti reali con
le narrazioni fantastiche intorno ai
fatti questo è un esempio molto
interessante che può aiutarci a capirlo
riconoscete che sono per quelli che
hanno una certa età il si è detto per
quello è un pochino più giovani e meno
netto il sì questi sono giocatori
americani de l'isle e paul glazier che
negli anni settanta recitavano la
formula il famoso telefilm starsky hutch
ora perché ve la faccio vedere questa
foto che ha giura girata recentemente
nel marzo 2017 nel mondo in italia
perché quasi tutte le agenzie stampa
quindi non i siti underground
complottisti eccetera hanno ripreso
questa notizia dicendo st schiaccia
amici per sempre e questa come vedete
l'ansa ora dove sta l'inghippo qua qual
è il fatto
e qual è la knapp e forse la narrazione
precede il fatto l'inghippo sta nella
questione che noi non sappiamo che cosa
è successo negli ultimi 40 anni dalla
loro due non sappiamo se sono amici veri
voi lo sapete no io no a meno che non
siamo giornalisti investigativi non lo
sappiamo e sappiamo soltanto che ci sono
due persone un po avanti con l'età che
si stanno dando la mano uno che poi
accompagna l'altro in carrozzina ma
sappiamo ci ricordiamo abbiamo vissuto
il racconto significativo di due giovani
poliziotti che si volevano redimere il
ricco rampollo biondo di famiglia che fa
il poliziotto per redimersi e il povero
moro a arcigno che fa il poliziotto per
redimersi e insieme costruiscono
all'amicizia eterna questi fatti sono
sempre più all'ordine del giorno questo
mix tra fatto in narrazione e per questo
ho esordito dicendo vistia siamo di
fronte non solo a grandi cambiamenti
tecnologici a grandi cambiamenti sociali
politici ed economici ma anche a grandi
cambiamenti culturali perché il rapporto
con la realtà che si sta modificando
dobbiamo imparare a farlo non è una cosa
semplice perché non viviamo più nella
realtà la realtà del novecento fissa
duratura vera stiamo vivendo nel
realistico che il racconto fantastico
del reale dove io posso prendere due
persone un attore americano è uno
sportivo americano posso fotografarli
posso
the contestualizzarli e posso costruirsi
una contro la narrazione politica sopra
li conoscete no sono michael jordan e
samuel jackson che in vacanza a forte
dei marmi quest'estate ad agosto sono
stati fotografati e questa cosa andata
avanti per molto ora voi mi direte vabbè
che problema c'è su queste cose si
decidono i destini geopolitici si
decidono i destini geo culturali si
decidono la legge o leadership si
decidono leggevo le tute shaun aziendali
parentesi forse non lo sapete la xbox
uccide i giovani teenager in america la
coca cola procura lights perché c'è una
bottiglia di coca cola che sembra bevete
di procura life eccetera eccetera sono
tutte dimensioni fantastiche qui
declinate nelle negativo che stanno
girando nella nostra conoscenza sociale
allora il grande tema per noi oggi che
stiamo parlando di cambiamento è questo
passare da quelle verità con cui siamo
stati educati con cui siamo cresciuti
che rimangono valide perché è un muro
che ho di fronte a un muro che del
fronte a un fatto ha però un
arricchimento rispetto a la possibilità
di incominciare a sviluppare competenze
narrative perché la narrazione si deve
imparare è anche un set di competenze
che ci possano consentire di riconoscere
i racconti che ci vengono fatti e
capirli e magari farci una risata sul
fatto che qualcuno ci dice che le sirene
esistono altra cosa molto importante
verificare sempre i fatti ma capire che
i fatti sono molto spesso soprattutto
oggi sempre più mixati insieme alla
narrazioni che le portano con sé per cui
non ci sono due persone anziane che si
aiutano ci sono star schiacci che
rappresentano l'amicizia eterna
infine ricordarci è questa la cosa forse
più difficile per noi uomini e donne del
novecento
perché non è vero che ci siamo ancora
abituati al nuovo e terzo millennio che
oggi stiamo vivendo in un tempo di
soggettività consensuale per cui una mia
foto
messa on line nel momento giusto con
tutta una serie anche poi di
accorgimenti certamente tecnologici
eccetera eccetera può spostare il
consenso molto più che una piazza
politica a roma oa milano
allora la grande questione diventa
abituarsi a percepire la realtà come una
grande simulazione dentro cui noi stiamo
vivendo che è fatta certamente delle
vecchie grandi verità con cui noi siamo
cresciuti ma anche con una nuova
componente di immaginario che non è più
relegabile come intrattenimento o
porzione così accessoria ma diventa
asset strategico
chiudo dandovi un po quella che può
essere una sintesi di molto semplificata
della possibilità di affrontare quello
che ci stiamo dicendo e cioè sviluppare
quello che le scene le scienze della
narrazione viene definita mente
narrativa che noi naturalmente abbiamo
perché noi pensiamo narrativamente ma
dobbiamo rendercene conto
e quindi provare a vedere come i
contenuti della nostra realtà sempre più
fantastica i contesti con cui questa
questi contenuti vengono profusi e le
connessioni funzionano se noi riusciamo
a fare questa cosa
diventiamo più consapevoli perché
l'altro grande tema oggi è la
consapevolezza di abitare in una
dimensione che non è più quella di prima
ringrazio molto
[Musica]
[Applauso]